y dada la minoría de la oposición en el
senado sería difícil que se concluyera
culpabilidad en el juicio político
contra el presidente sebastián piñera se
necesitarían 29 votos porque entonces
esta sesión tan larga y la importancia
de juzgarlo cuando está por dejar el
cargo
bueno porque los
como usted mencionó
los detalles que salieron a la luz
respecto de acuerdo a la venta de la
lámina que se realizó y las condiciones
de esa venta
en realidad fueron un shock para el
sistema político chileno
dado que apuntaban a
condiciones que el presidente en su
cargo estaba en condiciones de
asegurar y eso implica desde el verdad
esta investigación también judicial en
proceso de ser verdad significaría que
el presidente
tuvo la posibilidad de crear esas
condiciones para estimular la venta en
otras palabras aún sandro su cargo y
como tanto para la posición ha sido
importante así demostrar que nadie nadie
está por encima de la ley pero tiene
razón que las posibilidades de que
efectivamente sea destituido o sea
encontrado culpable profesional no son
altas dado que no son posibles no tienen
nuestros próximos votos
bueno influye este juicio político
contra piñera en los votantes que irán a
las urnas el domingo para las elecciones
generales y recordemos que anoche fue el
último gran debate entre candidatos
si es difícil saber si hay fluido no
en la última semana el candidato
que representa la continuidad del
gobierno sebastián fichar ha bajado en
las encuestas es difícil tener si eso
ustedes por sus temas por su desempeño
en los debates
anteriores que no tenemos suerte o si de
alguna forma estuvo afectado también por
este tema de los de piñera sin embargo
tuvimos un debate anoche como usted
menciona se hacían fichó y tuvo un buen
desempeño y no se tendría que en los
próximos próximos días recupere algo
desde ese partido el vídeo bueno y entre
los opcionados de los candidatos que van
a elecciones este domingo hay uno de
ultraderecha hay uno que representa la
izquierda y quisiera preguntarle de cara
a que chile enfrenta su proceso de la
constituyente y al siguiente presidente
le tocaría aprobar esa nueva
constitución como puede afectar a que
uno u otro lado gane la presidencia en
el tema tan álgidos como los de derechos
humanos que son los que nos llevaron a
esta constituyente
bueno claramente si llegara a ganar el
candidato nunca derecha ajuste antonio
kast
le tocaría un congreso probablemente un
congreso de oposición le tocaría también
la convención constituyente que tiene
una mayoría de constituyentes de
izquierda y de izquierda y sería difícil
para el gobernante debe ser difícil para
cualquiera
las noticias interesantes de las
elecciones del domingo va a ser el
resultado de la elección parlamentaria
casi más que es la elección presidencial
porque eso va a terminar la capacidad
que tenga lado el próximo presidente de
implementar su agenda y más encima
tenemos este asunto de la nueva
constitución que el gasto que al
implementar ahora en todo derecho humano
parte la discusión no es un derecho
humano de los derechos políticos los
derechos sociales que van a salir de la
nueva constitución
le va a tocar ese próximo presidente
incrementar y eso tiene implicancias
para muchas cosas incluyendo la
situación fiscal del país